in the name of the Father and of the Son and of the Holy Spirit, amen.
The reading from the Sinhaxadeon from Aeth, on which we commemorate the Holy Apostle
and Evangelist John the Theologian and the Holy Manor from his grave.
On the Aeth of the month, we celebrate the Sinhaxes in honor of the Ash or Holy Manor, produced
by the tomb of the Holy and illustrious Apostle and Evangelist John the Theologian, the Virgin
disciple and beloved of Christ, the friend who leaned on the master's breast.
After the entering into rest and wondrous burial of the Holy Apostle John the Theologian
at Ephesus, his tomb, which was found to be empty, became a source of miracles.
In particular, every year, on this day, it would suddenly be found covered with a sort
of ash that the Christians of the area called the Manor, and which had the property of being
able to heal the illnesses of body and soul of those who anointed themselves with it in
faith.
This miracle, thus, gave the church the opportunity of solemnly celebrating the beloved disciple
a second time each year.
Through the prayers of our Holy Fathers, O Lord Jesus Christ our God, have mercy on us
and save us.